pour et grand maman voilà michael vous
posez votre main tranquillement voilà
j'ai mis un petit poussin comme ça sur
vous venez pour cette opération du canal
carpien pas de gars ronny de paralysie
du membre supérieur comme c'est le cas
habituellement
mais une anesthésie locale une technique
venue du canada adoptée par le docteur à
part depuis deux ans
c'est un mélange d'anésthésie adrénaline
et c'est à dire que l'adrénaline
vasoconstricteur vaisseaux et les rapts
hisse donc en fait ça évite le
saignement
on a saisi toute la zone opératoire et
même si cette patiente est sous
anticoagulants c'est-à-dire un
médicaments qui fluidifient le sang et
bien l'adrénaline joue son rôle de vaso
constricteur ça ça vient pas pendant
l'intervention comme vous avez vu et
elle a pu se servir aussitôt de sa main
et sortir avec un petit pansement pas de
garos pas de sédatifs elle est pas à
jeun c'est un peu comme chez le dentiste
finalement s'il anesthésie ou allante
existe depuis 15 ans en amérique du nord
c'est une nouveauté sur notre territoire
la clinique des franciscaines à
versailles et la première en ile de
france à proposer cette technique et à
la faire découvrir aux chirurgiens
j'avais pas vraiment cette habitude
l'add on avait ça fait six mois que je
fais que ça pour la main et où je vois
vraiment changement c'est nous qu'ils
enlèvent saisit donc on suit le patient
du début à la fin
donc il est vraiment en confiance il n'a
pas quarante personnes différentes qui
va voir au bloc opératoire
une confiance qui se confirme à la fin
de l'intervention
cette patiente joue du piano et
craignait de perdre certaines facultés
mais c'est génial
la première chose que j'ai faite après
l'opération j'ai regardé si je pouvais
jouer
bon ben je peux jouer au c'est génial de
toute façon je reviens dans un mois pour
faire la main gauche piste sur les nerfs
mais aussi prothèses de pouce aux
opérations osseuse
la technique se développe pour permettre
de plus en plus d'interventions sur la
main et commence également à être
utilisé en chirurgie du pied